hello michael hi anna
how you doing can you hear me okay uh
yeah loud and clear this screen looks
good to me you have 45 minutes
okay great thanks thanks anna let me
just get started here
all right hey everybody uh welcome to my
presentation today
you know it's uh it's always fascinating
doing these
panels because you get to be exposed to
many different types of
um analysis in the market you know and
simon who just spoke
you know he actually was explaining
something that he discovered by looking
at the order flow and what i'll be
talking about today is
how to use the order flow um to follow
the money to find
winning trades so with that
with that in mind in this training what
i'm going to teach you what you'll
discover is
why order flow analysis shows you what's
happening
right now in the market that can affect
what happens next in the market you know
people always say oh you know what the
market is is random it's
it's not you know there's if if the
market was completely random
um there'd be sort of no point in
investing or trading in the market
and i'm going to show you how orderful
allows you to see the actual strength
and weakness in the buying and selling
you know it's not like
the markets just go up and down you know
markets are
not a living human thing living
breathing thing but you know markets
go from strength to weakness back to
strength back to weakness you know
that's what causes moves to happen
and order flow allows you to see that
in the market and lastly you know order
flow gives you an edge
over other traders because you're going
to be able to see things that
they don't see you know and and that's
the important thing you know
you aren't necessarily competing against
yourself you're competing against
somebody else sitting on the other side
of a screen
so just really briefly who i am you know
for those that are new to one of my
presentations my name is michael baltos
i've got over 25 years of professional
trading experience
literally at trading firms okay not 25
years of trading experience trading you
know in my house at part time
while i worked a full-time job no that's
what i did for living that's why i was
hired at these
firms you know i started on the cme
floor back in the 90s
if you wanted to get involved in trading
in the futures industry
that's where you got started you have to
go to the trading floor it's not like
now you try to get a job
you know at a bank or at a trading firm
and they'll be like well
you know where'd you go to college you
know did you study programming can you
program in this language you know in
that language
it's very difficult for people to get
involved
in trading nowadays but fortunately the
barrier has been lowered in the sense
that you know anybody can open account
it's quite funny you know people think
that
all of a sudden i just open account i'm
a trader no you really need to learn how
to trade
and you know i've worked my way up
literally from the bottom of the
industry to
the top of the industry i i finished my
professional trading career at jp morgan
as as vice president of futures trading
and after jp morgan i was in my early
40s i said you know what i don't want to
do this anymore on a professional level
because it was
essentially sucking the life out of me
you know even though jp morgan's a great
name
the pay was very well um i wasn't
satisfied with my life so i left jp
morgan and i started trading for myself
and a few years later i started
orderflows.com
and i was trading for myself using order
flow which i had been trading with
for you know decades at other firms
and the software that was out there you
know it was good enough
but i know that software can be much
better
right it can do analysis for you so i
took
an existing order flow software i met
with the programmer and i said hey you
know what
this is what i look at in the market put
it in the software so it'll help me
analyze markets a lot quicker because
you know honestly when i'm working at a
bank like jp morgan or commerce bank and
i got a question on something there's
always an expert i can call
right but when you're trading for
yourself you don't have access to that
information
and the software the data that's
available
can answer that question but you have to
have the right software for it
now the reason i bring that up is
because the charts that i use in this
presentation
are generated from my order flow
software but what i'm showing you today
can
easily be applied with other order flow
footprint software that's available
and the problem is if you don't know
what to look for you're not going to see
what i'll be talking about in the market
and
and that's why in this presentation i'll
be taking you through a bunch of
examples on
things that you could easily and quickly
apply
to your trading to make better more
informed trades but again this is not
about me
this is about showing you how order flow
can improve your trading results quickly
right it gets you up to speed as quickly
as possible
you know it's funny because like my son
i have a son he's doing
you know everyone's doing remote
learning nowadays and he's in in first
grade and he's the way they teach math
nowadays is a little bit different and
you know i just
say just keep learning you know
sometimes he thinks he knows it all in
first grade i'm like
you don't right and as traders we always
want to be growing
and growing and growing because once you
get complacent
thinking that you know everything you
realize
that you don't know anything now if you
stay until the end
i'll show you how to get a copy of my
book trading order flow
it's 150 pages you will get a digital
download you're not going to get the
actual hard copy
um and it's very informative you know
when i left jp morgan
that was what i wanted to do originally
was write a book and and that's what i
started to do
um in the year or two after i left jp
morgan and it really has a lot of great
information
and will help you as a trader
now just brief disclaimer you know do
realize that trading involves risk and
only risk capital should be used for
trading
so basic question right trading 101 who
moves the market
right people say well it's buyers and
sellers well it's not just buyers and
sellers
by itself it's the aggressive buyers and
the aggressive sellers
you know the aggressive buyers are the
traders who lift the offer or
the aggressive sellers are the ones that
sell into the bid but you and i
right me you know we're just small
retail traders right i used to be a big
trader at a big bank
but not anymore i'm just a small trader
i'm not going to move the market no
matter how aggressive i
am you know i could just i could buy the
offer okay
well i'm buying two lots that's not
gonna move the market
it's the buyer that buys 300 contracts
clears out the offer buys the next 250
that's on the offer
clears out that offer that's what causes
the markets to move you know traders
that move
the market are big size aggressive
traders
now when people talk about order flow
you know it sort of comes back to
the information that's generated from
the market right and most of us are
familiar with
time and sales right we've all seen the
time and sales chart right and
honestly it moves so fast that you're
not gonna be able to make heads or tails
of it
you know the data is overwhelming you
know you can sit there
at stair at the time and sales think
you've picked up something but by the
time you
react to it it's too late okay
don't overwhelm yourself with that you
know it just moves too fast for a trader
to process
you know but traders need to process the
information because it's invaluable
right the information you see on the
time and sales you may think it doesn't
matter
but really that's what goes into making
the chart that you look at
right and most traders they just look at
a normal bar chart they just look at
where the open
the high the low and the close of the
bar is
but if you look at time and sales you
know you'll notice there's different
colors
and you know if it's a green color it
means that was someone
buying the offer if it's a red color in
this case orange it means someone was
selling into the bid
right and the quantity so it's going to
tell you how much
was trading on the bid how much was
trading on the offer and that's going to
help you decide
um you know how aggressive the market
movement was
now traders developed the orderful
footprint chart i didn't develop it but
what the orderful footprint chart does
is it takes that information in the time
and sales
and to a lesser extent the dome and
transforms it into an easy
to read easy to understand format right
i mean
it's great to have that information on
the dome
but if you don't have a way to use it to
utilize it then
it's it's really useless okay and the
footprint chart
takes that information and puts it into
an easy to read format
and again you know order flow is about
understanding what the aggressive
traders are doing in the market
remember it's the aggressive sellers who
sell to the passive buyers
as the aggressive buyers that buy from
the passive sellers
and trying to figure that out on a dome
as just as
you would on a time and sales is very
confusing
right you're just going to have all the
puzzle pieces drop into your
you know in front of you and then also
you got to put it together but the
footprint chart
makes it a lot easier because from the
time and sales from the dome
when you organize the data based on how
it's traded you have a lot of data
points to analyze
and i just want to go through you know
briefly that the three main points of
order flow is delta
point of control and imbalances and
delta is the difference between the
aggressive buying and the aggressive
selling remember
order flow is about what the aggressive
traders are doing in the market that's
what moves the market
now the point of control is a volume
based piece of information is the price
level in a bar
with the most volume and you know if you
look at a chart
sometimes you know you wonder why why
does the market come right down to that
level
you know of the previous bar and then
reverse and go back up
well oftentimes it's because that's
where the point of control was that's
where the most volume was
on the previous bar and that's important
now imbalances
is related to aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers
and when you have an imbalance it's when
the aggressive buyers outnumber
the aggressive sellers buy a ratio
usually four to one again you can adjust
whatever ratio you want
um four to one would be 400 or more
and vice versa the aggressive sellers
outnumber the aggressive buyers
and again remember markets trade in a
two-way auction
they there's a bid and there's an offer
so
in the delta it's the net difference
between aggressive buying and aggressive
selling
when you have an aggressive buyer buys
one lot that registers as plus one in
the delta
aggressive seller sells one at the
market hits the bid that registers as
minus one now every bar is going to have
a delta it can be positive
it could be negative or it could be zero
and honestly when it comes on zero
that's just coincidence don't
try to read too much into it like oh my
gosh it landed on zero that must mean
something no
in my studies i haven't found any
relation on when delta landed at zero
on a number you know in a bar that that
was you know a precursor to some move or
not
um the strength and weakness of the
delta gives traders clues
as to what's happening right now in the
market so this is crude oil yesterday
right you see we had a nice sell-off
yesterday morning around
just after eight o'clock chicago time
but if you're
watching the delta you can see
that it was mostly negative
right before you had that big sell-off
right so that's telling you something
it's telling you you know what
the aggressive sellers are in control
right right now what you have is
not overwhelming selling but you have
sellers dominating
um every bar right now i mean you do
have one or two bars with some nice
positive delta but other than that
overall negative delta now imbalances
right imbalances is also deals with
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
but it deals with it in the two-way
auction right where delta just deals
with it on a bar basis
okay so when aggressive buyers outnumber
aggressive sellers by four to one or
more
and vice versa that's when you have an
imbalance right and that's in the
auction
okay most of the time the two-way
auction is trading in relative balance
right but one of the signs that the
market's starting to move in a direction
meaning get out of balance is when
imbalances start appearing
okay so you know for example let me i
don't think i have my
pointer on so here we go
if you look again this is the same chart
crude oil right
you see a couple of bars here with the
blue circle right this tell me there's
buying imbalances right i put on there
to show you it doesn't appear on the
chart that way
but you do have the imbalances right and
what happened you get this little tiny
move up you know it's just telling you
there's some buying
aggressive buying coming in here and
then right before you start selling off
what do you see a bar with two
imbalances a bar with three selling
imbalances a bar with
four selling imbalances right so this
move here is telling you
you have an imbalance in this market
whereas before you know it was
you had a bar with about six selling
imbalances seven and selling and
balances
but then it came back in balance right
the aggressive buyers came in
and moved it back it sort of went
sideways okay so even though you had
some buying imbalances here
don't get too excited because that's
just evening out what you had there but
now
you come up to sort of the swing high
you start going sideways
what do you see right you start putting
the pieces together delta
negative right minus 44 minus 31 minus
108.
selling the balances in the bar okay
that's telling you hey you know what
it's going to give you an opportunity to
get short
all right you get short here at 43 at
53.50
you just got a little stop right here
above this this little area here you
don't need to wait for it to sort of
break down and sort of fall apart down
here at 53.25
before you get short you could be
getting short up here once you realize
that hey you know what
i got aggressive sellers coming into
this market right i could see it in the
delta i could see it in
the imbalance
point of control again is is the price
level in the bar with the most volume
and it's important to know because yeah
i think of it as the balance area for
a bar and oftentimes traders get lost in
looking at volume and they don't even
look at the volume and it's important
because
not all prices trade equally okay
would you think a price level that say
say trades 20 contracts
should be treated the same as a price
level that trades 2000 contracts
no right if you've ever run a business
you know whether you're selling on ebay
or you have an actual brick and mortar
store
you understand how important value is or
sorry
volume is on something that you're
selling
in its relation to price and as
price starts moving lower right the
point of control starts moving lower as
well
it should because remember if you see
point of control as
balance in the bar right and you start
seeing point of controls
going lower lower lower lower lower
you're not expecting this market to be
going higher are you expecting it to be
going lower
so keep an eye on what point of control
is doing so
what do you have up here right we got
point of control
lower lower lower lower lower you got
selling imbalances
as point control is migrating lower
you've got delta
negative negative negative negative okay
do you think this market's going to go
higher no
every everything point of control
imbalances
delta is pointing to a move lower
all right i mean it's not rocket science
there's some science to it but it's not
necessarily rocket science so if a poc
point of control is migrating higher
that's bullish
if it's migrating lower that's bearish
all right keep it simple
so now that you understand how to start
using the data points of delta
point of control and imbalances it's
time to take your order flow analysis to
a step further
right because that's just you know sort
of the the pieces of the puzzle you sort
of the ingredients to make you know a
nice meal
but i'm gonna show you how to use it now
to follow the money
and when i talk about following the
money what exactly does that mean
well you know think of you know
the big shark being sort of the alpha
predator right
and you and me right the small retail
traders we are
you know the little fish swimming around
the big shark to pick up the scraps so
to speak
right i mean jp morgan or the big
goldman sachs and you know the big banks
are going to hoover up
um they're the big trader they got the
big size in the market
we are the small size what we want to do
is we want to swim along with them
right we want to be going in the same
direction we don't want to fight them
sometimes people think that you know
they they're better off
trying to fight the the big banks for
what
right the big banks consistently make
money day after day
um and if you're trying to fight them
it's just it's a losing battle so
if you can't beat them you know join
them just go along with them
but who are the big traders you know
it's more than just banks right you got
hedge funds you got commercials right
i've worked for commercial companies you
know cargill edf man the big
commercial trading companies so people
that own literally the the physical
product you know they grow it
they they ship it they refine it you
know make it into
you know and sell it to people to make
it to end products right and the real
money accounts you know that's something
that
doesn't really get talked about a lot
because it sort of gets lumped in with
hedge funds but i'm talking about
central banks right i'm talking about
pension funds you know these these are
people that have big size
you know they've got retirement funds
that they got to invest they've got
endowments they got to invest but
that's what they call real money but
honestly it doesn't get you know it's
not as
i don't know why it's not as glamorous
as so to speak as a hedge fund
but you know because the hedge fund
traders are high flyers but
you know all the traders that work at
commercials traders that work at real
money accounts
they also take home big salaries you
know you only hear about the big hedge
fund trader oh you know this guy made 20
million
a year but you know at places like
cargill there's guys making in the
millions
you know there's guys that work you know
for the microsoft pension account that
they also make millions because they
have to right if they don't
a hedge fund will come and approach them
and so
it sort of gets lost in the whole
conversation people just think banks and
hedge funds but there's
it's a wide spectrum of
what's considered a big size trader but
when these big size traders trade it
shows up in the tape
right in the time and sales and most
traders they can't see that activity on
their charts because
they're not looking at it right they're
just looking at a normal bar chart right
here this is
crude oil right i was just talking about
what was happening here in the order
flow
right up here at you know the 5360 to
53.50 area
right big sellers were dominating this
area because it was showing
up consistently in the order flow it
showed up in the delta
it showed up in the imbalance it showed
up in the point of control
right all three pieces turned negative
right
i hate to use the term confluence but
when everything is
is bearish in the market what do you
think is going to happen
it's not going to rally it's going to
it's going to sell off order flow is
going to show you when the big players
are active because you can see where and
when they're active by looking at the
delta
and the volume right the point of
control is volume
right you see the imbalances right if
you have imbalances right imagine
you know understand you understand what
an imbalance is right you have
more aggressive selling than aggressive
buying it's like with my kids okay i'm
one person
i got three kids well even though
you know we play tug of war i'm much
bigger than them
all right they all three of them can
pull do whatever but i'm going to win
right because i'm the stronger hand and
that's what big traders are and when you
see imbalances in the market
that's what's happening big players are
dominant right now it might not just be
one big player by itself it could be
you know a combination of of a bunch of
traders
but overall it is one traitor oftentimes
or a few big traders
um at the same time you know so you had
your first big push down here
second push sec third push right but if
you're watching
um the point of control on the delta you
could have seen it right happening
in here before as the second big push
down um started happening
and that was a nice move to have right
you could see it here right this was the
initial big push here
this was the second big push here this
was the third big push here
so you know even if you missed earlier
what was happening with the points of
controls move is starting to move lower
with the styling imbalances right you
notice that earlier you had a big
negative delta
then you had a big negative delta here
by the time it breaks out here you
should be convinced already you
shouldn't be
holding any thought that this market's
going higher
right and then you see the market just
fell over but look at the delta
all negative here all right
bonds right we had this nice move
yesterday in the bonds okay
you're just going sideways and then boom
it just took off right a move from
169.06
all the way up to you know 169.20 22.
right it would be nice to have a nice
you know something telling you that hey
you know what this market's getting
ready to pop and
rally and the order flow does right you
can see it here it's just sort of going
sideways you know it's not
making any sense right here it's just
you know trading bid in the offer
bidding the offer bidding the offer
but if you're watching the delta you
could sort of see yeah it's kind of
quiet 39 53
57 right 164. it's jumping
284 317 okay
right in here you can see the delta is
starting to grow point what's happening
with points of control
whereas before it was just basically the
same level here you got four points of
control at the same level
but now it's a higher point of control a
higher point of control
don't really have much in way of
imbalance yet you got one here buying a
balance one here buying and balance
but this bar you got one two three okay
so if you're not
yet convinced what's happening here with
the delta getting stronger to the
positive side that aggressive buyers are
coming in control
and that the point of controls are
moving higher by the time this bar comes
around
okay you should definitely be convinced
you know you should be getting in
you know as quickly as possible by this
point if you're not already long
you know from this 0 608
area you should be getting long by the
time you see these imbalances come in
and the strong positive delta
right and at least you would have gone
in a little bit later but you would have
had your confirmation
you know if you're not comfortable yet
in understanding that and that's the
whole point of these
presentations is not to sell you on some
service on
you know oh you should buy it here but
is to teach you how to trade
right i didn't spend 25 years
you know trading professionally
listening to other people giving me
trading
ideas you know yeah sometimes i would
listen to somebody and then
some form an idea but being able to look
at the market
and understand what's happening and take
a trade based off of that
is really the greatest in the world you
know it's validation that what you're
doing
is correct this was gold yesterday all
these charts are from yesterday
um so you can see this stuff happens
every day in different markets
you know what happened here on this big
push down
affected what happened here right
what happened as you're coming down
it attracted buyers right you got
five buying and balances here you got a
nice big positive delta then it just
goes sideways right then it tries to
make that push down again
and then the aggressive buyers step in
with a bunch of buying and balances
and a nice positive delta so what you
had here the aggressive buying
when the market started coming back to
that area again the aggressive buyers
reappeared right because at this price
level at this time they think it's a
good buy
right you just spent all that time here
going sideways
no direction then you know maybe these
people are saying well you know what i
bought here i'm not getting paid
then it starts coming down but then the
big buyers step in you know what and
they're thinking you know hey at 53
54 this is a good buy they step back in
and start buying it
and you can see every time it sort of
came down to this 53 and a half
there was aggressive buyers here right
three buying and four buying imbalances
two here nice positive delta 79
and later in the day what happened right
market went up
came back down came back down where to
that area
where you had the aggressive buying in
earlier so knowing
you know if you can reference where the
aggressive buying was
earlier when you come back down to that
area
and you see that aggressive buying
that's going to give you a nice low risk
trade because you know what you know hey
earlier i had aggressive buying here i
had aggressive buying here
so i could sit here throw a bid in here
somewhere
when the market's trading 60 61
yeah if it comes down here i'm going to
take that risk that
calculated risk that the aggressive
buyers are going to show back up
and what happened they did right and the
market went
back up so
hopefully by now you can see how the
order flow delta gives you vital
information as to what can happen next
in the market
again delta is just one part of the
order flow generated information
let's take a look at another part right
the imbalances right and again you know
that's the example i like to use
is a tug of war and it's not always
equal
right i said you know i could have tug
of war with my three kids i'm gonna win
all right but if i do tug of war with
three adults
i'm gonna lose all right so you gotta
understand that there's
in the market you have the same thing
you have small retail traders going
up against a big deep pocket
institutional trader right and
ninety nine point nine percent of the
time the institutional trader is gonna
win
you know this is ten years okay so it's
a five minute
chart all right ten years
move very slowly right and to get a big
move into 10 years is
is great and yesterday
right the market was just sort of going
sideways back and forth you know
it looked like it was about to break
higher sort of break out of this range
that he had been in most of the morning
and during the european session
and you know it trades one tick higher
from the higher the range from earlier
and then it falls back down and then you
know hits the other end of the range
people start thinking oh you know what
maybe it's time to get short
okay well if you're looking at something
like the imbalances
it's going to make a lot more sense to
you all right so
you know i can see people thinking as
this market starts getting short
right this is that area on the other
chart i'm showing you where the bars
were going down you got
sound and balance down and balanced down
a balance
no follow through here okay trace 22
contracts
then it comes right back with buying a
balance buying and balance buying and
balance
fine and balanced buying and balance
buying and balance right
imagine you buying it after you see one
two three what else do you see
you know i like to play this game with
my kids it's called what do we know
right when when
you know trying to do math with them you
know what you know sort of
put the pieces aside and figure out what
do we know okay well
i know that we hit this low here at the
22 contracts traded that's not very much
right
especially after a big sell-off in the
terms of delta minus four thousand seven
hundred ninety-five
minus five thousand you know it's
trading
two thousand contracts on the bid five
thousand three thousand fourth
the interest 22 where's the sellers
they're not there then it comes back
buying a balance obviously 22 against
2000 that's almost
200 percent you got a nice positive
delta
2 400. what's point of control doing
well this is your swing low here
point of control is higher than the
previous bar okay
next one point of control is higher
still you got another bind and balance
get negative delta okay
900. sort of throws a little spanner
into the works you know you'd love to
see nice positive delta
but this is actually mean something i'm
not going to get into it on this
presentation
um how markets rise on negative delta
and how it's important
then here another nice positive delta a
nice strong
um sorry nice big imbalance and nice
positive delta
and higher points of control over three
bars points of control migrating higher
right and you got the imbalances there
you had selling the bounces on the way
down
now you got buying is appearing right so
what do you think the market's going to
do
you think it's going to fall over and
start selling off again to the downside
no
it's going to start moving higher so if
you're getting along at 16
you know it gives you a nice move
methodical move up into the 20s
okay it's again you know you a lot of
times the order flow
there's nothing really going on right
markets exist to facilitate trade
but when the market is showing you
something
that's when you have to act right
wheat simple all right keep it simple
markets moving down you're seeing
selling imbalances
markets moving up you're seeing buying
and balances markets moving down
you're seeing selling imbalances right
don't need to over complicate it
right crude oil yesterday five minute
chart notice how
the big sell-off market went up and then
you obviously had that big num
big bar on the inventory number market
sold off came right back up
hit this area and then sold off again
right
do you ever wonder why the market stops
at a level
you know wouldn't you like to be a
seller here know that hey you know what
yeah i could put a nice low risk trade
in here i could throw an offer in here
right why are you going to throw an
offer in here as opposed to here
or here well let the order flow tell you
right and what you have here these are
stack
selling balances now in this case i have
the stacks on a balance set to two
levels again it's a five minute chart
but you can see right earlier on that
move down
you had the selling of balance if you
draw that selling and balance
all the way out it comes up right here
53.40
where'd the market trade up to 5340
even also on that way down right this
bar here if you're looking at a bar
chart you can't see these levels you
can't see where there's market imbalance
in the bar right and that's the value of
order flow
you can see there's another stack
selling a balance of two level stacks on
a balance here where the market do it
came right up to here
granted you know i don't know if you'd
want to take a trade
when the number comes out let you know
have something in after the number
okay but what happened 5315
market hit that number
sold off right when the data came out
fit down to 52 whatever that was 76
and then rally back up but you know what
you get filled here
you got to take profit you know 25 cents
away
a five tick stop you know everyone says
oh you got to have
certain amount of risk toward ratio
three to one five to one well you could
throw an offer in here risk five ticks
with a 25 tick take profit
that's your five to one risk to reward
you know just
as you know here right you had that
other imbalance here you get short here
another
five to one risk to reward ratio
right earlier in the day right
why did the market come right back down
to this level you know others say oh you
got a pin bar you know you should buy
those well you know if you trade pin
bars you got one here
you got one um here here you got a lot
of pin bars
okay but there's a reason why the market
came touched this level
and didn't get past it right
why is because you had a imbalance
coming in from earlier
right it came right in at that level
52.50
all right just imagine you just have a
bid in there working 52.50
boom filled market rallies up
25 cents 50 cents almost
you know 75 cents so you know there's
there's
value in the order flow right and that's
the whole point is
trying to show you the value and how you
can apply it to your own trading
now this is a look inside my software
right
and i'm just showing you you can choose
to draw out that line that i just showed
you in the imbalances right
i chose a stacked imbalance of two
because honestly if you're looking at
five minute charts or above
trying to get three is is difficult
honestly if a stacked imbalance of two
levels
holds over five minutes it's it's
important
okay and you can adjust the um
percentage so you don't want to use four
to one so you want to use
three to one two point five to one say
you want to use ten to one
you can adjust it right here you know
ten to one would be a thousand three to
one would be three hundred
five to one would be um five hundred
that's in percent
okay now this is e-mini one-minute chart
now granted i i did scrunch this chart
because it's trying to show a lot of
data
i like to look at a footprint i don't uh
really trade much off of a bar chart but
i just
scrunched this in so you can see these
levels here was a stack selling a
balance from earlier
right this one came in at 4 30 in the
morning more or less
what happened market sold off boom boom
boom came all the way back up
97 sold off to where
an area where you had a stack buying a
balance right in here
right then the market went back up you
know
you also had this one around five uh 510
stacks on a balance got within one tick
here then sold off
but you know then sort of ran in here
okay you got stopped out
fine just wait for the next trade you
take this trade you take this trade
you're done for the day it's 10 points
in in both directions
30 minute chart people say well
okay this one didn't work out here's
another level
right here it came right back up to that
level
cash open obviously you know people say
well yeah it only went down and it went
up but this is a 30 minute bar
you know i went from 96 down to 80 you
know it was at 82 and a half
you know that's uh what is that 14
13 and a half point move in this bar so
you could have
gotten something out of this move here
you know 13 and a half bar
point bar there's there's points to be
had again
in the middle of the night 10 o'clock
last the other night
right here right got a couple first one
came back later this one right here came
right back 3804
04 sells off over the next two bars down
to
94 down to 92 right that's another 10
points
again those are 30 minute bar charts
okay so you can see
whether you're looking at one minute
chart five minute chart
15 minute chart 30-minute chart the same
concepts of imbalances apply same
concepts of delta apply
same concepts of point of control apply
so hopefully by now you can see how
easily you can use order flow
imbalances to enhance your trading just
as you can use delta just as you can use
point of control and remember with
trading it's not about quantity taking a
lot of trades it's about quality
taking good trades order flow to me is
like
having a metal detector right because
you're going to discover things that
nobody else sees
right in other words you can see what's
happening in the two-way auction
that other traders are not seeing and
reacting to basically you know that's
what you're going to get your edge
right imagine it's like playing cards
playing poker with somebody
and seeing their cards right they can't
see yours you can see them
that's where you're going to get an edge
and that's what's going to separate
winning traders from losing traders is
having an edge
and an edge is a piece of information
other traders don't have
or something they don't see happening in
the market
right it's going to give you an edge
order flow gives you that edge
because you have information that
traders other traders don't want you
know they don't want to look at the
order i can't be bothered with that
stuff it's just a fad
no it's very valid information and it's
very useful information and i got news
for you
hedge funds are now actively
using those data points delta point of
control
imbalances in their trading
algorithm they're being programmed in
there
so over the last 40 or so minutes
hopefully you'll agree it's been time
well
spent right but again i can't cover
everything in a quick training
i got a youtube channel i've got a
couple hundred videos on there
different aspects of order flow you know
if you really want to
take a deep dive go down a rabbit hole
check out my my youtube channels order
flows
on youtube but if you want to get
started with order flow
i got a special offer everything you
need to know to get started
right and i got a special deal if you
act fast it's the order flows trader 3.0
runs on ninjatrader 8.
it's the volume footprint chart with 17
pre-programmed order flow tools i didn't
even talk about
any of those tools today i just talked
about sort of the basic
order flow things that you need to know
delta point of control
and imbalances and
it's very easy to set up right software
sometimes is so confusing you're like oh
my gosh why did i spend my money on this
i can't make heads or tails of it my
software order illustrator
two minutes to set up right and that's
just simple downloading it and
installing it onto ninjatrader you don't
need a template right because
the defaults are all set up for an
e-mini one-minute chart which is what
most people
start with right and normally i sell it
for 899 dollars but you're not going to
pay that today
this order flows trader 3.0 software is
like taking
my knowledge of trading order flow and
put it into a program so you can see
what institutional traders are doing in
the market it's like having me sit next
to you
and tell you hey this is happening
that's happening but
having good software is one thing you
need to know how to use it
right how to read the order flow right
you can have the best trading software
like you could have the best porsche
made but if you don't know how to drive
um good is it's going to be useless
right and so i just i give you a lot of
other information a lot of other
education
you can get access to my order full
trading course which i normally sell for
297. you get it for free
right i'll also give you access to 56
videos that i made for my inner circle
on advanced order flow tricks tips
analysis right you're going to get
access to that also for free
you start adding this up it starts
getting expensive you know honestly
education is expensive
but it's one thing to learn from videos
right it takes discipline and commitment
right but i also have live
group training right i've got over 104
sessions recorded right every tuesday
night
i do this from 7 p.m to 8 p.m central
time
and it's free when you get the software
you don't have to pay for extra
education you know some people do
here's my software spend two thousand
dollars on now if you wanna learn how to
use it
you gotta you know buy credits you gotta
join my trading room and that's another
a month that's stupid i give you this
extra information you come there you can
ask your questions
you know maybe having a problem um
setting it up or maybe you got a problem
you know
you're trading a market that you're not
sure what you should be looking at
ask me in that thing you know in that
weekly session
and what i talk about today is just a
sample of the forms of analysis that we
do in those weekly sessions
so if you start adding this up you know
it's quite expensive it's over
almost two thousand dollars but for a
one-time fee
of just 749 you can get the software
right so you go to orderflows.com3.html
and you just got to pay 749 that's it
once now the only other things that you
got to get
paid for obviously is your data fees and
it runs on ninjatrader doesn't run on
the other
platforms um you know if you have a paid
version ninjatrader you got to pay for
that but other than that there's no
other fees to me you know
if you upgrade it's free we've upgraded
made two major upgrades in the last
since we released the software in 2015
and they've both been free
but other people are saying you know hey
the software is remarkable it's very
helpful
i can see what's happening in the market
all right so you just go to
orderflows.com
slash off to three dot html scroll down
this page
click this button that says buy now
takes you to paypal i don't get your
paypal information your credit card
information
i don't get any of that stuff right it's
all handled through paypal
after your payment is processed then
you will be emailed the download
information the license tokens
the course log is now it's going to be
sent to your paypal email address okay
so if you use a different email
from your paypal email you're going to
need the email that you use with paypal
so again it's just a simple one-time
payment of 749.
that's it you know i'm not going to come
back say oh you got to pay another
99 a month forever and cancel it's going
to be like
you know pulling teeth no you know it's
just a one-time simple payment
749. no recurring fees nothing for me
now as a special bonus for investor
expos i'm gonna give you access to
my order flow playbook you know there's
like 11
orderful setups in there especially one
of my favorite courses
and i sell this normally for 297 but you
can get it for free
today when you sign up um through this
link orderflows.com3.html so get started
now
go to orderflows.com off three what
you're going to get the order flows
trader 3.0 the trading course the inner
circle video series
access to live weekly group training
forever you know i got people in there
that have been
with me since 2015 when i first started
and you get access to the overflows
playbook
so just get started 7.49 now to get my
book on trading order flow go to
orderflows.combook.html
and it takes you to this page right you
got to enter your name
and your email then you click submit
it's not going to be directly on this
page you got to enter your name and your
email hit submit
and then you'll take to the next page
will be the download page where you
could
save it to your phone save it to your
ipad
your computer print it up do whatever
you want with it so
get started that's the important thing
is you got to get started
someplace right it's 2021 it's january
now is a good time to
get started on something in the new year
so thanks anna
um i don't take up too much time going
over but that's it
everybody thanks for attending hopefully
you learned something that you could use
in your trading
so have a great rest of the week and be
sure to catch the next presentation
coming up
thank you so much michael have a great
rest of your week
thank you
let's move to our next presenter anka
medha
hello anka hey anna
i'm just getting ready to share my